everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and we are back and we're
going to be going over gained onto the
1972 World Chess Championship pick him
back up buddy Spassky and Bobby Fischer
so far Bobby Fischer has a two-game
advantage he has won four games and tied
two games but he Spassky has won two
games early on in his tied to so scores
five to three after eight rounds in just
a game eight Bobby Fischer had a really
good game with white pieces playing the
English opening which you really ever
play so in game nine buddy Spassky will
have the white piece is going to be
looking to get back on track since he
hasn't had a win in a few games now so
we'll go and get started with pawn to d4
Knight f6 upon C for Pawnee six nine f3
pawn d5 and then after Knight to c3
Bobby Fischer transposes into the semi
tada now sometimes you may see that the
regular - - without the Knights here on
F 3 + f6 but that's really because Bobby
Fischer wants to make sure he does not
have an isolated pawn so after pawn
takes if the knight was not here you may
recapture with your pawn here and it's
somewhat isolated you don't have your
epon to kind of help protect it and this
pawn here on c5 it usually wants to come
to c6 and kind of protect it so it's
kind of Simha isolated so that
particular case this line the scimitar -
allows you to play Knight to d5 and not
have the isolated pawn here your
opponent's usually not going to be
playing Knight takes on d5 this gives
black more of an attack than usually
black has in this opening the Queen
could take you could have to pawn
capture the Bishop takes all of a sudden
black is controlling the center of the
board you know yes the Queen could take
in the center but then just pawn
recaptures this is fairly good for for
black so usually even if the pawn were
to take this is still probably pretty
good if the pawn takes the bishop
recaptures if something pawn to e3 a
little bit slower from white you could
still see pawns to see for putting a lot
of pressure on white soap and this puts
your game as we usually
see whites can be playing pawn to e4
trying to solidify the center of the
board just kind of ignore this night on
at d5 then I it's going to come down
here take on c3 ponder e captures pawn
takes on d4 and then Knight to c6 so a
nice little opening from both sides we
don't see this defense quite that often
in the Queens gambit declined lines just
because we have so many other really
good options but Bobby Fischer always
likes to think outside the box and
definitely came prepared for this
opening but a Spassky then continues
Bishop to c4 getting ready to castle on
the King side and then we see a nice
little novelty from Bobby Fischer it's
move we hadn't seen really in this
opening up into this point in 1972 but
he plays pawn to b5 if it was me it
makes total sense just Bishop e7 getting
ready to castle on the King side you're
playing a fairly defensive opening it's
very sound but it's not very aggressive
you're not really looking to you know
counter-attack in any crazy ways but he
decides to go and play pawn to b5 and it
is somewhat protect they can't play
Bishop takes on b5 because there's Queen
down a5 check this bishops going to fall
so nice little attack here forcing the
Bishop to move Bishop comes back here to
d3 and then Bishop to b4 so Bobby
Fischer although playing a very
defensive opening still trying to be
aggressive in this so after Bishop to b4
a Bishop to d2 we do see an exchange on
the board and then pawn to a6 just
solidifying this pawn chain right here
on the Queen side but he's fast he
continues with pawn to a4 and then
castle on the King side and then Queen
to c3 now but he's basket would really
like to castle on the King side as well
get some King side safety but he has to
be aware that there's a lot of pressure
on this pawn on d4 so he correctly
played Queen to c4 but if you had castle
down the Kings side it gets tricky
Knight down taking on d4 the knight
recaptures on e4 then the Queen swoops
in here this Bishop can't really move
because as soon as it moves this Queen
is going to fall it can't protect this
square in any different way so pawn
could take on b5 Bishop here - b7
attacking even this pawn right here
since the bishop's kind of protecting it
but it's not really protecting it
because the Queen would fall so putting
a lot of pressure on white you could see
a continuation now some of these
variations could change depending on how
each opponent plays but these are some
of the more optimal moves pawn takes on
a six the bishop takes on a six a rook
up here to a three trying to protect the
square here on d3 since it is being
attacked rook over here d8 just putting
even more pressure on d3 rook a1 just
double-barreling here to attack on this
Queen side the a file Bishop b7 starting
to attack the pawn now a rook takes
Bishop takes on a8 Queen up here to a5
all of a sudden this is this is going to
be dangerous for white to deal with pawn
to h6 if there is any sort of
shenanigans here then the King can just
come here to age seven not really where
white wants to be in the game so instead
he decides okay I've got a pretty good
opening right here I'm gonna go and play
Queen to c3 not going to worry about any
of the stuff going on with the d4 square
and then just continue from there Bobby
Fischer Bishop to b7
so he's completed his development now
white eventually will need to castle on
the king son pawn takes here on b5 we
see the recapture and then castle on the
King side Bobby Fischer a Queen to b6
just getting ready to prepare the push
of this pawn on the B file if we kind of
look from Bobby Fischer's he doesn't
have a lot going on except pushing this
pawn he does have this past pawn and he
can start to push for britty Spassky can
maybe start to blow up some of the Queen
set on this a file but other than that
maybe you can start to push on the the
Queen side but both the King size are
pretty safe there's not a lot of
material that's putting a lot of
pressure nothing's really going to be
coming of this any time soon
so both sides just trying to find small
little things that they can do Bobby
Fischer pawn to b4 is kind of his only
plan right now rook to be one to start
to try to slow that down as much as
possible pawn to b4 a queen coming back
here to d2 not up here to d4
we do see in exchange right away Queen
to d4 but then the rook can just come
back here take
on b4 since it is being protected by the
Queen on d2 Queen back here at d7 so
both sides not really doing anything
crazy they're not getting out of line
where we may see some crazy variation
that could lead to some complications
both sides they're just kind of playing
normal chess if you would call it that
and that's sometimes what you see with
the scimitar it's a very defensive and
sound - opening but you usually can't
mess it up too much and your opponent
can't really find too many holes in the
defence Queen here - III rook over here
d8 just trying to double up in the
center of the board
rook over here B 1 trying to attack on
the Queen side Queen down here - d3
after the capture rook here - d3
rook takes on a b7 so just exchange in
material right now pawn here to g5
making sure there's no a back rank make
back rank mate so the King can easily
come here to g7 if he wants to look up
here to b8 kind of forcing in exchange
right here I'm after King to g8 no side
is going to win this no one's going to
make that big of a mistake so it's kind
of a drawing game they decide to go and
play it out a few more moves pawn up
here to f3 rook to d2 H for h6 after
pawn takes on g5 both sides decided to
go ahead and call it a draw so but he
Spassky really needed to win with the
white pieces unfortunately he was not
able to and Bobby Fischer rege you know
keeps his two-game lead going into game
10 so both sides not the longest match
but all in all still some great chess so
hope you guys enjoyed this video
hopefully you enjoyed the fact that I am
back making videos all in all thanks for
watching and I'll see y'all in the next
one